we're gonna show you this clip from your
very first interview okay
okay ready
survivor millionaire the other show is a
run for its money
we hope it gives millionaire run for its
money survivor
we hope we are just as successful if we
are just as successful survivor
that's a good thing what do you remember
that about that and what
i look let me just say this i love this
short hair i wonder
if we had even aired yet because
i sound pretty like arrogant
like we're going to give this big show
run for its money and then it was like
like we didn't look like we ever would
we didn't even look like we finished the
season
so we're going to get like cancelled
mid-season i'm like what are we going to
do send it
everyone home like how does that work i
can't get over how
thin my eyebrows were
and that was considered fashionable then
i think 20 years ago
hi i'm julie chen welcome to big brother
did you really ever understand what big
brother would become
when you first started this adventure
absolutely not
as a matter of fact even after the first
season started
i had no idea because you may or may not
remember
but everyone hated big brother season
one
they critically hated it they hated the
show it wasn't survivor they hated me
i wasn't jeff probst and i was being
compared to not just
you know this juggernaut survivor but
there were other really popular
popular quote unquote game shows reality
shows like who wants to be a millionaire
was on prime time
so they're like well she thinks she's
regis and she needs to tone it down and
she's not and
the weakest link was more popular all
these other shows
and they were they wrote the show off
me off i wrote it off i was like yeah
i'm not too crazy about it either season
one and
i agree with you like i didn't know what
i was doing i came from news
and i was like how do i be you know a
prime time host you know instead of just
being a news person
so i had a learning curve and i never
thought we'd still be here
and talking about a 20-year anniversary
and that's
is it a little bit like how you like me
now that we have built that this is a
franchise that is every day that people
can't live without like
it is a fanaticism with big brother
i felt that way you know probably
ten years ago eight years ago like i
still felt like the insecure
you know we still have a lot of haters
and it was until maybe like season eight
or nine
that i started like puffing out my chest
a little bit
and being like yeah i work on big
brother
you know and i'm not embarrassed to say
it and i know you like it
and if you don't you haven't checked it
out check it out and i dare you to call
me say you don't like it